comment se compare maintenant le canada
aux autres pays qui sont engagées contre
le groupe armé état islamique
faudrait que dans les faits qu'elle a
été la part des frappes aériennes
canadiennes
alors pour ce faire on va regarder
l'ensemble des frappes militaires qui
ont été lancées depuis le début de
l'offensive il ya 18 mois maintenant
avec les états unis un peu les chefs de
la coalition
en fait depuis 18 mois il y a eu à peu
près dix mille frappes militaires qui
ont été faites quand l'état islamique ce
soit en irak ou en syrie 80% de ses
frappes quand même ont été lancés par
les états unis évidemment ce sont les
chefs de cette fameuse coalition le
canada là dedans quand il fait et bien
regardez
en fait depuis le début de
l'intervention au canada ou en irak
surtout un petit peu en syrie c'est 2 6%
de l'ensemble des frappes militaires
alors quand on regarde aussi le nombre
de sorties qui ont été faites par les
fameuses cf-18 en avait six là bas donc
un navet 1300 et seulement un cinquième
de ses 1300 sortie avait en fait pour
objectif des cibles militaires parlant
la participation la plus concrète de ces
pays à la coalition comment est-ce qu'il
se démarque alors c'est une grande
coalition qui varie de mois en mois au
fur et à mesure qu à d un pays qui
s'investissent davantage d'autres qui se
retire au complet on a à peu près 65
pays et organisations
parmi les têtes d'affiché évidemment le
royaume uni l'australie la france les
pays-bas l'union européenne et
l'allemagne est aussi des petits pays
qui ont décidé de s'investir à des
degrés on va dire un peu plus marginaux
par exemple il ya la moldavie il ya
l'islande ya panama également in taiwan
alors bien sûr à côté de cela il y a les
grands pays qui sont meneur en termes de
mobilisation militaire donc évidemment
les américains en tête trois mille cinq
cent cinquante soldats
une centaine de membres des forces
spéciales qui vont être envoyés dans les
prochaines semaines 150 avions de chasse
et plus la france 3500 militaires qui
ont été mobilisés 38 avions de chasse
1200 soldats c'est la première fois que
l'allemagne sous anglais merkel a décidé
d'envoyer un contingent militaire sur un
terrain et puis et aussi la russie
on sait pas trop dans lequel le court
elle joue c'est la vie naturelle de
assad en même temps elle participe à un
peu parfois avec la coalition il ya deux
mille militaires de base militaire
installée et plus d'une centaine
d'avions de chasse quand même le
meilleur aussi des pays qui jouent un
rôle non militaire oui parce que c'est
une vaste opération évidemment il n'ya
pas juste aller sur le terrain il ya
comme une organisation par exemple
comment on fait pour arrêter le flux
d'une
grand étrangers qui sont vont combattre
en syrie auprès de l'état islamique
il ya les pays-bas et la turquie par
exemple qui s'occupe de ce dossier là
comment couper les sources de
financement et bien c'est l'italie et
les etats-unis qui travaillent sur ce
dossier là l'aide humanitaire on a dit
l'allemagne également les émirats arabes
unis le canada bien sûr participe on a
vu aujourd'hui avec le dévoilement de
cette aide humanitaire
et puis on va aussi tenter de dévoiler
la nature de l'état islamique
enfin faire la promotion de ce qu'on
appelle cette fameuse coalition et
surtout de montrer à quel point l'état
islamique et dangereux donc là on parle
encore une fois des états unis et des
émirats arabes unis vaste tâche en effet
merci frédéric